son características solo de la ciudad de
slobians donde nos encontramos sino de
las mayoría de las ciudades en el don
vas donde si bien la Luz va y viene
durante las horas de la noche las calles
permanecen oscuras y aquí en eslobians
donde nos encontramos hubo el gran acto
de las fuerzas militares que celebran su
día hoy en Ucrania aquí estuvo el
presidente de bolodomírse lensky y
Aunque realmente no se le vio en las
calles el público luego un video en el
que se leía que estaba la entrada y se
reunió con un gran número de militares a
quienes rindió honores por la labor que
libran en esta zona de Ucrania donde él
bien lo dijo celebran las principales
batallas actualmente y esto es
especialmente evidente en la población
de backmud en la provincia de donest que
si bien los rusos las fuerzas rusas
están tratando de tomar desde meses de
junio y de Julio han reforzado batalla
en los últimos días los soldados y la
poca población que queda ahí están en
sótanos son atacados permanentemente y
también por un gran número de refuerzos
de las tropas rusas que son en mayor
número después de ese reclutamiento
masivo de los últimos meses aún así los
ucranianos siguen teniendo el control de
esta población y de muchas otras de esta
región del presidente que le recordó hoy
que espera que el año entrante esta
provincia esté totalmente en control de
Ucrania y es que recordemos que la lucha
aquí se Libra desde el 2014 contra los
separatistas de estas provincias de
dones y Luján que ya tenían en su poder
bastante territorio y que se ha ido
aumentando desde que comenzó la guerra
el 24 de febrero esto también es llega y
este visita de Selene es que llega en un
momento en que las situaciones bastante
dura porque han bajado las temperaturas
estamos a menos 10 grados centígrados y
esto es bastante especialmente para los
soldados que están en el frente